When planets are destroyed they form an asteroid
belt, between Mars and Jupiter there is an
asteroid belt… was there a secret planet
there?
A few weeks back, we talked about how the
Death Star could blow up the planet of Alderaan
resulting in the formation of an asteroid
belt.
And that got me thinking…
WE have an asteroid belt…
I wasn't the only one: on twitter, viewer
Shawn Pitts asked: do you think that OUR asteroid
belt was a planet once.
And if it was, how big was it?
The Asteroid Belt, which strangely doesn't
have a name, it's just called "The Asteroid
Belt" or "Main Asteroid Belt," sits between
2 and 4 astronomical units from the Sun past
Mars and before Jupiter.
It's comprised of millions of space rocks
ranging in size from small pebbles to the
largest known asteroid Ceres; which is 600
miles in diameter.
So was there a planet there?!
From what we know of the birth of our solar
system, no… there never was, but ALMOST.
Gravity is the support structure for the formation
of celestial bodies.
Gravity pulls material together so it can
form stars, moons, planets, galaxies…
Too little or too much and they won't form;
and that area between Mars and Jupiter is
the latter.
Too much gravitational interference caused
it to become a bunch of rocks instead of a
pretty little planet.
Physics dictates how far away those bodies
have to be from each other to maintain stable
orbits.
This was discovered in the late 18th century
by J.E. Bode, and is called the Titus-Bode
Law.
Essentially, each planet's orbital period,
is equal to the period of the sun's rotation
and distance of the furthest reaches of their
orbit.
According to this mathematical equation, there
SHOULD be a planet in between Mars and Jupiter,
and a planet TRIED to form but Jupiter's massive
gravity tore it asunder.
It just couldn't do it.
Of course, we know that NOW, but from the
18th and into the 19th century, people believed
they simply hadn't spotted the elusive planet
yet.
And then in 1801, Giuseppe Piazzi discovered
Ceres!
He believed Ceres might be a comet, but it
didn't have a 'coma' the gas and dust that
surrounds a comet.
A bit over a year later, a German named Heinrich
Olbers discovered another small object on
the same orbit he called 2 Pallas.
Eventually, as more of these were discovered
astronomers knew there was no planet in this
fifth orbit, but instead… what they called
asteroids.
Despite what conspiracy theorists may say
on the internet; these billions of little
asteroids never formed into a planet.
Instead, the gravitational forces of our solar
system kept it as bit of rock and dust.
But, since Shawn Pitts wanted to know how
large a PLANET would be if it DID happen to
form, I figured we could give a guess.
Today, Ceres, comprises one-third of the mass
of the whole asteroid belt.
If you were to glomp the mass of the whole
belt onto Ceres, you'd STILL have less mass
than our moon does!
Dr. Ian O'Neill, space producer for DiscoveryNews
says our moon would still be 26-times more
massive than this super-Ceres.
More like super tiny.
Asteroids DO occasionally fly by Earth, which
some would call, "a close shave," but if you
want a REAL close shave, try Harry's.
Thank Harry's for sponsoring this episode.
I use harrys twice a week to shave my neck
and The blades are sharp, and the aftershave
smells great.
A starter kit includes 3 razors, a handle,
and your choice of shave cream or foaming
shave gel (I like the gel!).
Go to harrys.com now and get your starter
kit for only 15 bucks and with our code DNews
you
can get 5 dollars off!